I'll tell you what the problem is though
they have a Kamala Harris problem it's a
significant problem it's true and the
problem the problem is I don't think
it's the way you think I'm gonna say it
the Kamala Harris problem is
they cannot they they cannot be right
okay let's skip her over I I especially
a white guy no wait there is a solution
though
AOC Michelle Obama oh you're right will
she I mean she says no I mean you made
more insight than I am we don't hang out
okay I'm surprised I was shocked here
that I'm sorry that I was misinformed
um she decided that she wanted to enter
The Fray I think not only should win the
nomination she wins the election and it
creates by the way probably without even
contesting a primary or general because
she would simply walk into the
convention Joe Biden would have an
instant medical need to depart and at
the convention it would be viewed as
this kind of dramatic unifying electric
moment she would walk in the Michelle
Obama banners would would go up